this idiot said I don't know what
Draymond does out there he said I don't
like Draymond at all you don't know me I
just don't like Golden State I quite
frankly wouldn't like a team that beats
me all the time either I don't like
anything to do with them quite frankly
you you were a little kid in high school
watching us win championships should be
happy that you even witnessed that or
maybe college but you get the point
you're a fan Draymond talks a lot you
talk a lot now so if you have four rings
sure you talk a lot more
for All Stars you probably talk a bit
more
defensive player of the year
you for damn sure would talk more two
Olympic gold medals
you definitely would be talking because
that would mean you you'd be Team USA
and
we all know how that goes so gets away
with a lot too
what exactly do I get away with I have
15 texts one less than your dumb ass
okay great his game is cool if you ever
wondered
why do Memphis Grizzlies is not ready to
compete for a championship look no
further than this idiot right here
they're actually depending on this guy
to help them win a championship and he
says his game is cool quite frankly that
just shows how little you know about
basketball and yeah y'all you running
around talking about a dynasty the
dynasty starts after you
not with you he plays with heart knows
the ins and outs of the defense you want
to be quite Frank I made the ins and
outs of our defense I guess that's why
they like him over there
I'm trying to figure out why they like
you in Memphis
or do they like you in Memphis that's a
better question I'm not sure your
teammates like you but I can tell you
why they like me over there
when you contribute in the way that I
contribute I have contributed to four
championships they tend to like you so
next time you speak up on me you should
do some fact checking next time you
speak up on me you should do some soul
searching
next time you speak up on me
I hope you in a better situation than
you and now where the guys you play with
actually enjoy playing with you because
they actually think you're contributing
to winning
cause it ain't happening right now chat
ah you're not a champ
you're a clown
it ain't happening for you